who'd survived the longest in the zombie
apocalypse one two three everybody we
are Kelly Clarkson she'll show and we're
here to perform our new song and we're
gonna play a funny game and that game is
most likely to you who would be your one
phone call if you got arrested
ah three - what are you cam
oh yeah what what he have a lot of money
no I'm smart yeah Oh solve the problem
buddy yeah who's snoring can be heard
next door wait why there's a lot very
new easy yeah yeah yes okay how much you
work with the quail you might be snowing
right now - who gives the best life
advice three two one Oh God
[Music]
who'd survived the longest in the zombie
clips
one two three why amazing local news
anchor ankle ankle ankle ankle okay
three two one Minya know what you
already MC ah Korea fancy in Korean the
music program look like ten o'clock show
thank you so much gonna have a
performance at Kelly Clarkson show with
a new single you can on my heart
yeah don't miss out thank you so much it
was Massa ass thank you subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going